[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to our podcast
my name is Si Co and I'll be your host
today so without further Ado let's dive
into today's episode and share a great
journey together get ready to be engaged
entertained and inspired today's topic
will be about the impact of social media
on our friendship
in the ever evolving landscape of the
digital age the pervasive influence of
social media has become an undeniable
Force shaping the Dynamics of our
friendships in profound and intricate
ways this podcast seeks to explore the
multifaced impact of social media on the
fabric of our social connections delving
into both its positive contributions and
the challenges it poses to the depth and
authenticity of
friendships the positive threats one of
the undeniable merits of social media in
the realm of friendships lies in its
abil ability to Transit geographical
boundaries platforms such as Facebook
Instagram and Twitter provide a virtual
bridge that spans
continents allowing individuals to
maintain connections with friends
regardless of physical distance through
the lenses of social media we can
witness and participate in the lives of
friends sharing in their Joys
achievements and even the mudane aspects
of their daily existence this continuous
stream of updates Fosters a sense of
continuity creating a shared narrative
that bends in individuals together over
time moreover social media serves as a
catalyst for the discovery and
explorations of shared interest by
joining groups following pages and
engaging in in online communities
individuals have the opportunity to
uncover common passions that may have
not been readly apparent in their
offline interactions this not only
deepens existing friendships by
providing new avenues for connection but
also opens the door to the formation of
new bounds based on shared hobbies and
Pursuits the collaborative nature of
platforms such as Google Docs or
Pinterest facated groups project Pro s
and shared planning enabling friends to
collaborate seamlessly even when miles
apart these platforms become digital
canvases uh where friends C create
strengthening the sense of shared
accomplishments and fostering a unique
form of
camarad the shadow of
challenges however admidst the benefits
lie the shadow of challenges and and one
prominent aspects in the potential for
social media to breed feelings of it
quantity and the notorious fear of
missing out as individuals create
carefully selected fragments other their
lives for public consumptions friends
may find themselves measuring their own
lives against these C created depictions
these result in in often a disorted
perspection of reality leading to
self-doubt envy and the pervasive sense
of not measuring up to the idolized
standards pres presentated on social
media furthermore the Allure of of
anonymity in the online realm
contributes to the darkest side of
social media's impacts on friendships
cyber bullying shielded by the virtual
cloak of
anonymity individuals may engage in
hurtful
Behavior under undermining the trust and
com uh
camaraderie that forms the foundation of
friendships the consequences of online
conflicts can re
reverberate into the offline World
injecting a toxic element into the
Dynamics of personal
relationships the con the constant uh
bomber
bombardment of carefully create Crea
um lives on social media can also
contribute to a sense of
isolations paradoxically the more
connected we are online the lonlier we
might feel in the real world friends may
miss out the the sub
sual of nuances that make face Toof face
interactions rich and meaningful leading
to a potential erosion of the depth of
friendship
navigating the complex complex
ability in navigating the complex
terrain of social media and friendships
a mindful approach becomes imperative
authenticity emerges as a guiding
principle encouraging individuals to
share not just the highlights but the
challenges and vulnerabil
vulnerabilities that make relationships
genuine the cultivation of empathy
becomes equally crucial as friends
strive to understand the uh the created
nature of social media and its potential
impact on percept perceptions
establishing healthy
boundaries in the digital realm ensures
that friendships are not overshadowed by
the constant
influx influx on online information and
the pressure to conf to confirm the
social expectations
building on this social media literacy
Emer emerges as a video uh vital
skill vital skill in maintaining healthy
friendships understanding the algorithms
recognizing the illusions of Perfections
and acknowledging the impact of online
behavior and M mental well-being are
essential components of navigating the
social media landscape
friends can actively engage in open
conversation about their online
experiences experiences fostering a a
supportive environment where the
potential pitfalls of social media
social media are acknowledged and
mitigated in conclusion the impact of
social media on friendships is a
tapestry woven with with threads of
connection and challeng challenge while
it serves as a powerful tool for
maintaining for maintaining and
enriching relationships social media can
induce complex utilities related to
self- prospection comparison and the
potential for online conflicts
navigating this integrate landscape
demands on
an new
nuanced uh understanding of the digital
Dynamics out of play and the committed
at fostering authenticity empathy and
healthy boundaries in the pursuit of
meaningful and res resented
friendships as we continue to ride the
wave of techn technological ad ADV
advancments the role of social media in
shaping friendships will
undoubtedly evolve recogniz recognizing
the potential p Falls and actively
working toward harnessing the positive
aspects will be in
instrumental in in ensuring that our
friendships not only withstand the
digital age but thrive in the midst
thank you so much for listening to my
podcast I hope you have a great day
bye